[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
pour son premier grand voyage avant le
départ pour new york le paquebot france
a pris contact avec l'atlantique les
canaris ces îles de l'éternel était
était le but de la croisière qui a
permis à 1600 privilégiée de découvrir
la joie de vivre à bord de la nouvelle
ville flattant plongeurs limite à la
piscine mais des amateurs décidé pour le
gymnase
une fréquentation honnête des
nourritures de l'esprit à la
bibliothèque 2000 valu
le bar ne manqua pas non plus de clients
disons de visiteurs qui évidemment la
décoration seul ne pouvait manquer
d'attirer
[Musique]
la salle à manger quant à elle autour de
madame de gaulle la marraine du france
faisaient si l'on peut dire l'unanimité
ainsi ce robin et le personnel et les
différents services chargés de donner
son rythme à la vie du navire
le soir venu la musique entraînait les
couples comme il s'y est aux soirées des
vacances de luxe
un bateau qui fait la vie belle elle
aura été en somme la conclusion des 1600
qui furent de la croisière au canada
[Musique]
la caravelle a depuis longtemps conquis
les airs et la célébrité on connaît
moins son père spirituel l'ingénieur
pierre siv qui fut le créateur génial de
ce magnifique appareil air france en
baptisant du nom de sa ville natale
grenoble la 28e caravelle de son armada
qui est en même temps la 100ème sortie
de lusine a tenu à lui rendre un hommage
mérité
on pouvait craindre à l'occasion de
l'anniversaire du 24 janvier qu alger ne
céda à une nouvelle vague de violence il
n'en a heureusement bien été si de
nombreuses fenêtres ont pavoisé la
présence très apparente de puissantes
forces de police dans les rues privées
de transports publics et dans les
grandes artères interdites à la
circulation des véhicules manifestait la
volonté du gouvernement de ne pas voir
s'installer à nouveau le désordre le
calme donc n'a pas été troublé le centre
de la ville conserva toute la journée
son caractère paisible par petits
groupes les algérois 20 déposé des
fleurs au pied des arbres près desquels
tombèrent voici deux ans les victimes de
la fusillade
à 17h magasins et bureaux fermaient
leurs portes une foule nombreuse se
rassemblent à près du plateau des
glières et aux alentours de la rue
charles péguy au-dessus lesquels
passaient et repassaient l'hélicoptère
de la police et cette foule soudain se
figea pour une pathétique minute de
silence alger pendant sept minutes en
honorant ses morts at elle pu jusqu au
fond repenser le grand problème qui
l'agitent et qui hélas a troublé et
trouble encore temps de conscience
[Musique]
sucre de canne sucre de betterave la vie
moderne us indifféremment des deux mais
se souvient ton de cet autre temps où le
sucre de canne en jolie pin aiguë orné
seuls les rayons des épiceries
il fut un temps en effet voici plus d'un
siècle et demi ou les plantations de
canne à sucre des antilles et de
louisiane étaient seuls pourvoyeuses
d'une industrie où s'approvisionner le
monde entier or les guerres de la
révolution puis de lempire ni en péril
dans ce domaine l'approvisionnement de
la france la flotte anglaise avait coupé
la route du sucre et napoléon fit
rechercher un produit de remplacement un
ersatz comme on dit aujourd'hui ce fut
benjamin delessert un fils de banquier
qui utilisant les travaux intérieurs par
vata experts le sucre de betterave est
présente à l'empereur voici juste 150
ans les deux premiers pains née de son
industrie
l'empereur lui décerna immédiatement la
première licence de fabrication qui
comportait une exemption d'impôt est à
visiter la première fabrique
industrielles établies au village de
passy en un lieu qu'on peut encore
déterminer mais qui a depuis bien changé
d'aspect n'y en 1814 200 fabrique du
même genre fonctionner en france et
produisait annuellement trois mille
tonnes de sucre trente ans après leur
nombre atteignait 500 le succès de
benjamin delessert c'était donc affirmer
sans toutefois convaincre tout le monde
car si napoléon satisfait pas le décor
est lui-même de la légion d'honneur les
détracteurs ne manquaient pas et la
presse du temps transmis nombre d'échos
de la guerre des deux sucres ou la
betterave en général n'avait pas le beau
rôle
en dépit de cette bagarre la betterave
gagne à la partie et les quelques 400
mille hectares consacrés en france
chaque année à la betterave en sont la
preuve la plus formelle les moyens
mécaniques d'aujourd'hui
l'amélioration des transports ont amené
depuis quelques 25 ans une concentration
industrielle dont les installations sont
capables de produire pour certaines de
30 à 40 mille tonnes de sucre par an
mais devant ces machines qui presque
sans le secours de l'homme sont passés
d'un mouvement continu de la betterave
brutaux morceaux de sucre calibré
pensant un instinct à la première
sucrerie de passif et de nos un coup de
chapeau à benjamin delessert
[Musique]
grande foule à vincennes pour le prix
d'amérique
40 millions de prix et un duel attendu
new star à fond de mme hasina qui lui
rend 25 mais ça n'est pas encore le
moment de la passion madame et monsieur
rêve
quant à cette autre monsieur ils
hésitent
[Musique]
attention ils vont partir ils sont
partis
[Musique]
vous allez voir new star numéro 13
prendre la peine voici new star qui se
détache
elle accentue maintenant mettra pas
naître son avance les autres concurrents
sont lâchés
m
finalement mme hasina n'ayant pas pu
remonter son handicap new star ne sera
pas rejointe et c'est dans une très
belle foulée qu'elle franchit le poteau
d'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
21e rallye automobile de monter card
4000 kilomètres contre 350 équipage
partie des quatre coins d'europe ont
passé trois nuits et quatre jours sur
les routes
[Musique]
cette année le temps s'est révélée
beaucoup plus clément que les années
précédentes et 120 équipages réussiront
à parvenir au but final monte carlo
néanmoins les concurrents rencontré sur
leur chemin neige et verglas qui
provoquèrent quelques dérapages
[Musique]
après avoir abordé une des dernières
difficultés du parcours on plonge
surnoté carlo où l'équipage suédois carl
sonnac bonne sur sable numéro 303 arrive
en tête
il reste encore des preuves de vitesse à
discuter mais au décompte final des
points ce sont les suédois qui
triompheront dans ce 31e rallye
[Musique]
suivant la tradition les trophées leur
sont remis par les souverain monégasque
[Musique]
à
les succès d'elvis presley de paul anka
de vince taylor et de johnny hallyday
ont fait école toute la jeunesse de rap
est saisi par l'europe et même en
pologne où des amateurs s'efforce
allègrement de suivre les traces de ses
funambulesque héros de notre époque
[Musique]
j'avais des billets
m
[Musique]
et qu'on ne s'y trompe pas ce n'est pas
un public de 12 illuminés qui se
pressent à cette présentation ce serait
plutôt des connaisseurs les
approfondisse heures des philosophes du
rhum
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons allons il y a de l'espoir
que
[Musique]